dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui on va
essayer de calculer ensemble
l'expression de l'énergie cinétique et
de l'énergie gravitationnelle en
physique classique mais à partir de la
relativité générale
la relativité générale c'est une théorie
qui est plus précise et donc on va faire
des approximations pour se replacer dans
le cadre classique avec des vitesses
faibles par rapport à la vitesse de la
lumière et avec des champs de gravité
qui sont faibles par rapport à celui
d'un trou noir par exemple en espérant
qu'on retrouve les expressions de ces
différentes énergies dont on a
l'habitude
bon alors commençons on va imaginer un
objet comme une balle par exemple qui se
déplace avec une certaine vitesse dans
l'espace disons que sa vitesse s'appelle
V et la balle se déplace à proximité
d'un corps massif comme la Terre va
supposer que ce corps massif est
sphérique et statique et de masse grands
thèmes donc dans le cas où on a un
espace temps qui contient un corps
sphérique et statique cette géométrie
d'espace-temps est décrite parce qu'on
appelle la métrique de Schwarzschild
c'est ce qui va nous permettre de
calculer les distances ou les produits
scalaires dans l'espace-temps donc c'est
ce qui nous donne la géométrie de
l'espace-temps
et elle s'écrit de la façon suivante
DS carré est égal à c² DT carré
facteur de 1 - RS sur R
+ Dr carré sur 1 - RS sur R
+ R carré d'effi²
alors non justement j'ai fait une erreur
ici on a des signes moins j'ai mis des
signes plus ces décisions c'est ça qui
est vraiment très étrange en relativité
c'est que lorsqu'on calcule une distance
donc ce DS carré c'est le carré de
l'hypoténuse dans un triangle et bien au
lieu d'ajouter les carrés des différents
côtés on soustrait les carrés qui
correspondent aux composantes spatiales
donc le DS carré c'est le carré de
l'hypoténuse d'un triangle le DT ici
c'est le côté dans la dimension du temps
le Dr c'est le côté dans la dimension
radiale donc c'est une coordonnée
d'altitude alors c'est pas vraiment
exactement la distance par rapport au
centre mais c'est une coordonnée qui
quantifie l'altitude par rapport au
centre et puis si pareil c'est une
coordonnée qui mesure l'angle autour de
d'un axe alors c'est côté comme je les
appelle en fait ce sont des intervalles
de coordonnées et c'est pas des
longueurs physiques on est en trois
dimensions avec une dimension de temps
et deux dimensions d'espace donc en fait
on a deux points
qui sont éloignés
par un intervalle temporel
un intervalle donc DT un intervalle
radial et puis potentiellement un
intervalle d'angle défi et puis donc ce
qui est très étonnant par rapport au
théorème de Pythagore par exemple qui
nous donnerait que ds carrés serait
simplement dx² + D y² + DZ carré vient
là on a des signes moins et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'étrange et
c'est ce qui est propre à la relativité
et c'est ce qui fait la différence entre
le temps qui est positif et l'espace qui
est négatif
alors précision un peu ce que sont tous
ces termes comme on l'a vu les dtdr défi
et des côtés ou plutôt des intervalles
de coordonnées le petit C ici c'est la
vitesse de la lumière et le grand RS ici
c'est le rayon de Schwarzschild c'est
une constante qui dépend uniquement de
la masse de la planète
et ces données par deux GM sur C carré
où j'ai la constante de gravité de
Newton et c'est la vitesse de la lumière
donc dans le cas de la Terre ce rayon de
Chartier va environ la taille d'une
bille
alors ce qu'on va faire tout de suite
c'est simplifier cette expression en
séparant le temps et l'espace
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est écrire que
ds carré c'est égal à C carré DT carré 1
- RS sur R
moins la distance dans l'espace que je
vais noter simplement des Sigma au carré
donc en fait ça ça permet d'avoir la
distance entre les deux points dans
l'espace et si on ajoute ce terme ça
donne la distance totale dans
l'espace-temps entre deux événements à
noter que le temps t ici c'est le temps
d'un observateur très lointain de la
planète puisque en relativité le temps
est relatif donc le temps de notre objet
en particulier qui se déplace et qui est
dans un champ de gravité et différent de
ce petit t
bon et bien voilà on a la métrique sous
une forme plus simple et maintenant on
va vouloir calculer l'énergie de notre
objet
et lorsque nous dit le théorème de
notaire c'est que puisque notre métrique
d'espace-temps ne change pas au cours du
temps puisqu'on a cette invariance et
bien on va avoir une grandeur qui est
conservée cette grandeur c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'énergie
alors le théorème de notaire c'est assez
complexe on l'abordera certainement dans
une autre vidéo donc je vais pas m'y
attarder ici parce que nous dit le
terrain de notaire quand on utilise
cette métrique c'est que l'énergie grand
eux est égal à MC2 multiplié par T point
alors on va voir tout de suite ce que
c'est et multiplier par 1 - RS sur R
donc ça c'est l'énergie de notre objet
tel quel est mesurée par un observateur
très lointain l'observateur justement
qui mesure le temps t
alors qu'est-ce que T point ici bien t
point ça va être la dérivée du temps t
donc de la position de notre objet par
rapport à l'horloge de l'observateur
lointain dérivé par rapport au temps
propre taux qui est le temps que cette
fois-ci l'objet mesure sur son horloge
donc en fait c'est la dilatation du
temps c'est le rapport entre le rythme
auquel s'écoule le temps de
l'observateur lointain et le temps de
l'objet qui se déplace
et donc si on veut calculer l'énergie et
bien ce qui compte ça va être de
déterminer ce DT sur des taux
alors comment faire ça et bien pour
faire ça on va utiliser le fait que dans
l'espace-temps tous les objets se
déplacent par rapport à leur temps
propre à la vitesse de la lumière donc
en fait ça ça veut dire que tous les
objets donc si vous avez l'espace-temps
alors je vais représenter une dimension
de temps et une dimension d'espace bien
tous les objets se déplacent vers le
futur et le long de leur trajectoire il
se déplace à la vitesse de la lumière
petit C il se ils peuvent se déplacer
dans l'espace à une vitesse plus plus
faible c'est la projection de leur
vitesse sur l'axe d'espace mais leur
vitesse totale dans l'espace-temps c'est
toujours la vitesse de la lumière
alors en fait ça c'est un peu une
convention on pourrait choisir un
vecteur vitesse deux fois plus grand et
dans ce cas ça reviendrait à changer les
unités de temps qu'on utilise et donc
justement le facteur C ici la vitesse de
la lumière c'est un facteur de
conversion pour convertir un rythme
d'écoulement du temps en une vitesse
spatiale et d'ailleurs généralement ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on multiplie
également la coordonnée de temps par la
vitesse de la lumière pour obtenir une
coordonnée qui elle est même unités
qu'une distance et donc pour que
l'espace-temps soit mesuré avec les
mêmes unités dans toutes les directions
bref ce qu'on veut c'est que la vitesse
de notre objet dans l'espace-temps soit
égal à C
alors comment faire ça et bien on va
prendre deux points très proches sur la
trajectoire donc disons ce point ci et
ce point là
alors ces points sont espacés par des
écarts de coordonnées et en particulier
par un écart temporel qu'on peut noter
DT
et puis la distance ici entre ces deux
points c'est ce qu'on appelle ds ce que
nous dit la relativité c'est que le
temps propre mesuré par l'objet lui-même
sur son horloge c'est simplement égal à
la distance qu'il parcourt dans
l'espace-temps en fait le temps c'est
vraiment la distance et une mesure de la
distance que vous parcourez dans
l'espace-temps donc en particulier DS
est égal à des taux l'écoulement du
temps sur l'horloge de l'objet entre ce
point et ce deuxième point
alors ici puisqu'on veut une distance et
qu'on a un temps il faut multiplier par
une vitesse pour convertir les unités et
c'est là qu'intervient la vitesse de la
lumière donc on sait que ds doit valoir
c'est des taux
or on peut utiliser cette formule là de
la métrique pour obtenir l'expression de
DS
ce que nous dit cette formule c'est que
ds carré donc on peut remplacer par ça
au carré donc ça fait carré des taux
carrés est égal à tout ça donc est égal
à c² DT carré facteur de 1 - RS sur R
moins digma carré des Sigma carré en
fait des Sigma c'est l'écart spatiale
entre ces deux points c'est la distance
spatiale qui sépare c'est deux points
alors là c'est génial puisqu'on a DT et
des taux et donc on va pouvoir résoudre
ça pour obtenir DT sur des taux
alors commençons par diviser par C carré
des deux côtés on obtient que des taux
au carré est égal à DT au carré facteur
de 1 - RS sur R
moins des Sigma carré sur ces carrés
alors maintenant qu'est-ce que c'est que
ce des Sigma carré et bien on a dit que
c'est la distance dans l'espace que
l'objet parcourt en un temps d'étau ou
en un temps d'été donc en fait c'est la
distance qu'il parcourt en un certain
temps donc c'est simplement sa vitesse
fois le temps qui s'est écoulé distance
égale vitesse foisante donc ceci ça va
être la vitesse de l'objet qu'on a noté
V au carré fois le temps qui s'est
écoulé donc des T au carré
et diviser par carré
alors ici il faut faire très attention
si on utilise DT carré ça veut dire
qu'on définit cette vitesse comme étant
la vitesse mesurée par l'observateur
lointain ou en tout cas par rapport à
son temps et non au temps propre de
l'objet qui se déplace mais dans tous
les cas si on mettait DT carré ou des
taux carrés lorsqu'on va faire
l'approximation pour revenir dans le
cadre de la physique classique ça fera
aucune différence
on obtient des taux carrés égales DT
carré facteur de 1 - RS sur R
moins V carré sur carré
et alors là on a presque fini il suffit
de diviser des deux côtés par des taux
carrés et par tout ça
et on obtient que DT carré sur DT au
carré
est égal à 1 sur 1 - RS sur R moins V
carré sur C carré
et donc que DT sur des taux c'est la
racine carrée de tout ça
c'est génial on a obtenu l'expression de
DT sur des taux et donc on va pouvoir
l'injecter dans ce témoin qui était DT
sur des taux donc pour finir l'énergie
de notre objet c'est MC2 x tout ça donc
c'est MC2 sur Racine
de 1 - RS sur R
moins V carré sur C carré
multiplié par ce dernier termes donc x 1
- est sur R
et voilà l'expression de l'énergie quand
on n'a pas fait d'approximation en
relativité générale
en particulier on peut commencer à
remarquer plusieurs choses si l'objet
est très loin en dehors du champ de
gravité alors tout ça vaut 0 puisque
petit air tend vers l'infini c'est la
distance par rapport à la Terre et si
l'objet ne se déplace pas alors Vevo
zéro ici tout ça vaut 1 et donc on
retrouve e=mc2 pour un objet en dehors
du champ de gravité et qui ne se déplace
pas on a bien e = MC2 maintenant plus
l'objet se déplace vite plus ce terme en
bas va être petit et donc plus son
énergie va être grande effectivement un
objet qui se déplace à une énergie
cinétique donc on commence à retrouver
des choses qu'on connaît de la physique
classique
mais pour aller plus loin on va faire
des approximations on va faire ce qu'on
appelle des développements limités en
utilisant deux approximations la
première c'est qu'on va dire que RS sur
R est très petit devant un alors ça
effectivement c'est le cas on a dit que
RS c'est le rayon de chartil ça fait à
peu près la taille d'une bille alors que
petit air c'est la distance de l'objet
au centre de la Terre ce qui fait des
milliers de kilomètres donc c'est
effectivement très petit et puis on va
dire que V carré sur C carré et là aussi
très petit devant un ça c'est encore une
autre bonne approximation dans notre
quotidien les objets se déplacent
beaucoup moins vite que la vitesse de la
lumière et donc le rapport V sur C au
carré est très petit par rapport à
donc en faisant ces deux approximations
on va retourner dans le monde de la
physique classique
alors c'est parti on a que E est égal à
MC2
x 1 - RS sur R
/ 7 racines alors on va pouvoir ici
utiliser un développement limité c'est
le fait que racine carrée de 1 + x quand
X est très petit c'est à peu près égal à
1 + X sur 2 donc ici on a 1 + - v carré
sur C carré donc en fait on va pouvoir
retirer la racine et diviser tout ça par
deux donc c'est parti on divise par 1 -
RS sur deux r moins V carré sur deux
carrés
maintenant on remarque qu'on a une
fraction et donc on a quelque chose de
la forme 1 sur 1 + X avec X très petit
c'est tout ça
et ça on peut faire un autre
développement limité et on sait que
c'est à peu près égal à 1 - x donc on va
pouvoir remonter tout ça en disant que
c'est à peu près égal alors d'ailleurs
pour la rigueur je vais écrire à peu
près également
facteur de 1 - RS sur R ça ça change pas
facteur de tout ça on le remonte et on
change le signe donc les plus deviennent
des moins et si c'est des moins donc ça
devient des plus donc on a un plus RS
sur deux R + V carré sur deux c'est
carré
alors j'ai pas précisé mais si tous ces
développements limités on les fait à
l'ordre 1 en réalité si on voulait avoir
plus de précision on aurait des
puissances supérieures de X mais si on
les néglige on néglige toutes les
puissances supérieures de ce rapport et
les puissances supérieures de ce rapport
bon très bien et bien on a presque
terminé il suffit de développer ce
produit donc tout ça est à peu près égal
à mc² facteur de 1 x 1 ça fait 1 1 fois
RS sur deux r ça fait RS sur deux R
1 fois V carré sur deux carrés ça fait V
carré sur de ces carrés
- RS sur R X1 donc - RS sur R
ce - est sur R on va pouvoir le combiner
avec ce plus RS sur deux r là on a -1 +
1/2 donc ça fait moins 1/2 donc en fait
en soustrayant ça c'est comme si on
changeait le signe ici par un signe
moins
et enfin le produit de ça avec ça et
bien c'est quelque chose à l'ordre 2 on
a ce rapport là foi lui-même donc on
néglige et le produit de ça avec ça
c'est aussi quelque chose à l'ordre de
c'est le produit de ce rapport très
petit avec celui-là et donc on néglige
également donc on a terminé et voilà les
trois termes qui contribuent à l'ordre 1
à l'énergie de notre objet
alors ça vous dit peut-être pas encore
quelque chose si on remplace le rayon de
chartile par son expression on avait dit
que le rayon de fertile vaut 2 GM sur
ces carrés donc ici on a deux GM
sur C carré les deux s'annulent
et là la magie va opérer si on multiplie
ce mc² pour chacun des termes on obtient
que l'énergie est à peu près égale à MC2
moins
gmmc2 les C2 s'annulent et on obtient
GMM sur R
+ les C2 s'annulent on obtient MV carré
sur deux donc un demi de M V carré
et voilà l'expression de l'énergie au
premier ordre
donc c'est assez magique on a retrouvé
l'expression de l'énergie de gravité en
physique newtonienne de l'énergie
cinétique un demi de MV2 et puis on a
une énergie qu'on avait pas forcément
envie d'avoir mais on obtient
gratuitement grâce à la relativité c'est
l'énergie de masse qui provient du fait
que l'objet possède une masse et donc il
a intrinsèquement une énergie le fameux
e = MC2